as far as we can tell in Shakespeare's
time there was a not a fixed category of
erotic object choice that someone was
either homosexual or heterosexual let
alone bisexual just a term that didn't
have either and the absence of such a
term of a distinct sociological category
it's been argued at least has a distinct
cultural effect among other things it
produces a weird phenomenon legally
Shakespeare's time had exceedingly
unpleasant laws against sodomy and those
laws which were on the books are often
taken to be signs of a kind of toxic
viral homophobia scholars have done a
lot of work on the actual legal record
and it turns out that almost no one was
prosecuted under those laws the cases
that come up are ones in which a handful
a tiny handful of cases in which people
were crying out in pain for example
being evidently assaulted in bed and
they said please don't assault or
whatever but they didn't actually pursue
the laws now the question is why didn't
they push with laws sometimes having
ferocious laws insanely punitive laws
makes it difficult for communities to
actually prosecute under those laws
because human lives are what they are
and because actually if you start down
that road you would wind up killing a
lot of people in your society
shakespeare's world and this is an
aspect of shakespeare's world i don't
completely understand had what seems
like a perpetual bed shortage or rather
something like the other way around
people like sleeping with each other in
the same bed back in 1980 very long time
ago I went for the one and only time in
my life to China and I remember staying
in a place called the friendship hotel
yo a big one which was the kind of
hostel student hostel at that time when
people were having showers they what the
students were having showers they went
around and said does anyone else want a
shower and I was struck by at the time
because
the point is not that there was a water
shortage in Beijing as far as I know but
that people felt that was something
slightly odd about having a shower by
yourself clearly something anti-social
are weird people wanted to have showers
together something like that seems to
have been the case in the 16th century
people slept in the same bed the same
sex couples slept in the same bed for
much of their adolescent lives we don't
know what happened in those beds but we
think that as far as I can tell at least
that the police weren't called the
question is when of the police called
under what circumstances are is the
culture worrying about whether someone
is X or Y and Shakespeare's culture as I
say had laws on the books that indicated
that it was worried in a technical sense
but the laws were not as far as we can
tell enforced and certainly not enforced
in that place well is it a better world
from the point of view of homophobia in
some sense not at all it's much worse
but in some sense quite distinctly
better in any case Shakespeare seems to
have inhabited a world in which it's
much more possible to express homosexual
passion as we would now call it and
probably to enact that passion without
triggering a kind of social crisis